en octobre dernier Audrey vigilance le
réseau européen de surveillance des
traitements médicaux a publié un tableau
où on voit la présence de 25000 rapports
de personnes décédées peu de temps après
s'être vacciné comme vous pouvez
l'imaginer cette nouvelle a alimenté le
mouvement anti-vaccinal sur le réseau
sociaux et dans les rues selon lequel
les vaccins sont avant tout dangereux
mais ce chiffre montre-t-il vraiment que
les vaccins sont dangereux
bon cette fois je ne vais pas faire
durer le suspense et je vais mettre à
l'écran un très bon King que j'avais
publié sur Twitter il y a plus d'un an
en bref non le chiffre de 25000 n'a
absolument rien de surprenant c'est en
fait même légèrement moins que l'ordre
de grandeur que j'avais anticipé il y a
plus d'un an pourquoi donc et bien il ne
faut pas oublier que malheureusement il
y a beaucoup d'autres raisons de mourir
que le vaccin lui-même en fait chaque
année on estime qu'une personne sur 100
meurt c'est ce qu'on appelle le taux de
mortalité il peut être aussi bien dû à
un cancer qu'un accident ou plus
probablement encore à un AVC ou
simplement à la vieillesse mais donc du
coup en l'espace d'un mois soit 12 fois
moins de temps il y a environ une
personne sur 1000 qui malheureusement
meurt maintenant réfléchissez à
l’intervalle d'un mois qui suit la
vaccination d'un individu quelconque
pris dans l'ensemble des personnes
vaccinées même si la vaccination n'avait
absolument aucun effet pendant ce mois
qui suit la vaccination il y a bien une
chance sur 100 que la personne en
question meurt mais alors sur les 200
millions de vaccinés en Europe on
s'attend à ce que une personne sur son
meurt un mois après la vaccin bon
effectivement il faudrait multiplier par
le nombre de doses reçues mais restons à
un sur 1000 pour simplifier voilà qui
fait déjà 200000 personnes qui en 2021
sont mortes moins d'un mois après s'être
vaccinée alors on peut imaginer que dans
beaucoup de cas la mort est clairement
un tribuable à une cause autre que la
vaccination et que beaucoup de cas ne
sont pas rapportés à eux de ravigilance
mais alors parmi beaucoup de cas
restants la famille a vu l'un des siens
se faire vacciner développer les effets
secondaires de la vaccination et mourir
dans le mois qui suit la vaccination dès
lors les familles déjà réticentes au
moment de la vaccination vont sans doute
contacter Audrey vigilance et signaler
une mort après vaccination le fait qu'il
y ait 25000 de ces cas n'a alors rien de
surprenant
alors la vidéo aurait pu s'arrêter là
mais j'ai quand même envie d'insister
sur la raison pour laquelle le chiffre
de 25000 peut paraître aussi trompeur à
de nombreuses personnes car cette
statistique est loin d'être la première
à être trompeuse et c'est loin d'être la
dernière il est donc important de
développer de meilleures réflexes pour
se prémunir de mauvaises interprétations
de tel chiffre et bon j'aurais pu aller
dans plein de directions différentes du
biais de confirmation au raisonnement
contrat actuel qui inviterait à comparer
la proportion des morts chez les
vaccinés à la proportion des morts chez
les non vaccinés en passant par le
paradoxe de Simpson qui conduit à
surévaluer le cas des personnes a priori
vulnérables mais le point sur lequel
j'aimerais insister aujourd’hui en
particulier c'est le problème du biais
de sélection et pour bien illustrer je
vais d'abord vous parler du biais du
survivant vous avez sans doute déjà
entendu des célébrités comme Steve Jobs
parler de la source de leur succès par
exemple Steve Jobs a dit la chose
suivante je cite vous devez faire
confiance à ce qui suit votre intuition
votre destinée votre vie votre karma et
quoi que ce soit d'autre cette approche
ne m'a jamais trahie elle aura fait
toute la différence dans ma vie
bon j'ai envie de dire que l'intuition
de Steve Jobs aussi poussé à soigner son
cancer avec des médecines alternatives
et que ça ça a pas très bien fini pour
lui non mais dans sa de côté au moment
où il dit cette phrase l'intuition de
Steve Jobs semblait en effet lui avoir
permis de connaître un succès que très
peu de gens connaîtront dans leur vie ne
faut-il donc pas l'écouter si ça a
marché pour lui est-ce que ça ne
marchera pas pour nous et bien ce qu'il
faut bien voir c'est qu'il y a là un
biais de sélection énorme en se
concentrant sur un individu unique on ne
met tous ceux qui comme lui on fait
confiance à leur intuition mais qui
contrairement à Steve Jobs n'ont pas
connu un succès professionnel
époustouflant après tout la plupart des
entrepreneurs se fient probablement
beaucoup à leur intuition mais la
plupart d'entre eux échoueront
contrairement à Steve Jobs xkd et
peut-être celui qui illustre le mieux ce
biais de sélection dans un dessin
intitulé survive on y voit un vainqueur
de loterie effectuer un discours où il
affirme que jouer à des jeux d'argent
encore et encore sans relâche avec
abnégation et persistance ça finit par
payer et le tout bien sûr on prend sa
propre personne comme exemple voir comme
preuve sauf qu'il faut bien voir que si
cette personne a été invitée à prendre
la parole c'est parce qu'elle a gagné à
la loterie autrement dit parmi
l'ensemble des joueurs d'argent la
conférence a sélectionné uniquement la
personne qui a gagné j'imagine que ce
sera particulièrement le cas si la
conférence est organisée par une
entreprise de jeux d'argent comme la
Française des jeux par exemple bon bien
sûr une conférence avec une personne qui
parle de l'abnégation à jouer à des jeux
d'argent c'est pas tout à fait le plus
standard en pratique bien sûr la
personne a invité est plus un sérieux
entrepreneur qui a fini par faire
fortune souvent d'ailleurs grâce à papa
et maman qui ont sans cesse remis un peu
de sous dans la machine à startup et
dans ce cas le phénomène reste bien le
même l'exemple de la personne invité est
en fait très trompeur car il y a eu un
énorme biais de sélection des
ordinateurs de la conférence qui ont été
invité cette personne qui a connu le
succès parmi tous ceux qui se sont
lancés un jour dans l'expérience
entrepreneuriale généralement le biais
du survivant qui consiste à mettre toute
la lumière sur 1 survivant ça va
constituer un biais de réflexion énorme
dès lors que l'ensemble des survivants
est un tout petit ensemble de l'ensemble
des personnes qui ont fait ce que le
survivant déclare avoir fait et alors
dans le cas des vaccins ce sont
davantage en fait les morts qui sont
rares l'écrasante majorité des gens ne
sont pas morts du covid qui soient
vaccinés ou non vaccinés donc le simple
fait de mettre toute la lumière sur les
morts c'est induire un énorme biais de
sélection autrement dit ça nous donne
une image très biaisée par rapport à
celle qu'on aurait si on contemplait
tout le monde mort et vivant on a ainsi
le même problème quand on s'attarde au
cas des admissions en soit critique et
qu'on oublie de regarder l'ensemble de
toute la population comme illustre cette
super image du site du monde et bien sûr
on retrouve ce biais de sélection bien
au-delà de la médecine par exemple
imaginons une émission TV qui cherche
constamment à organiser des débats entre
des positions opposées une telle
émission chercherait par exemple à
opposer un scientifique qui croit au
changement climatique un scientifique
qui le né mais rien qu'en faisant cela
l'émission crée nécessairement un énorme
biais de sélection car le scient qui nie
le changement climatique n'est jamais
pris au hasard dans la population de
l'ensemble des scientifiques bref il
faut faire très attention lorsqu'on a
affaire à des données issues du biais de
sélection il ne faut surtout pas prendre
ces données comme argent comptant or
malheureusement ce biais est absolument
omniprésent surtout dans les médias mais
également dans les publications
scientifiques comme on en a déjà
longuement parlé sur saint
et alors un réflexe trop présent c'est
de se dire que si les données sont
biaisées alors on ne peut rien en tirer
et qui vaut mieux tout jeter à la
poubelle voir que ces données est toute
analyse de ces données ça ne peut pas
être scientifique et certes il vaut
mieux tout jeter à la poubelle plutôt
que prendre ces données comme argent
comptant mais si on y réfléchit bien
même des données biaisées sont en fait
informatives et même parfois très
informative imaginons par exemple une
entreprise qui sous prétexte de secret
professionnel et de protection de
données personnelles de leurs clients
refusent de partager leurs données et
leurs algorithmes avec qui que ce soit
imaginons que notamment pour son
business l'entreprise a pourtant
effectué énormément d'analyses en
interne de sa montagne de donner et
supposons enfin que cette entreprise
soit très critiquée pour des activités
illégales et même pour être une menace
de sécurité nationale par exemple en
promouvant massivement les discours de
haine et bon donnons un nom à cette
entreprise disons à ce moment-là je suis
pas
Facebook au hasard et donc poursuivi en
justice notamment disons par disons des
victimes de génocide au hasard cette
entreprise a alors tout intérêt à
partager des données qui la protègent
mais imaginons que cette entreprise soit
alors incapable de fournir de telles
données et au lieu de ça prend la parole
pour disons annoncer un changement de
nom de son entreprise alors que j'ai
envie de dire
osef un peu pas mal et pour révéler un
nouveau projet de metaves sur lequel
l'entreprise travaille et imaginons que
au contraire les rares documents qui ont
liqués de cette entreprise montrent au
contraire que l'entreprise est très
dangereuse en fait c'est pire que ça
Facebook a réagi au lit de ces données
rendant beaucoup de ces données internes
inaccessibles à la quasi-totalité de ses
employés bon vous m'avez vu venir même
si je me suis lancé dans la fiction ce
dont je viens de parler n'en ai
absolument pas une je cite afin d'éviter
d'autres fuites les paramètres d'accès
internes aux discussions de recherche de
Facebook sur des sujets tels que la
santé mentale et la radicalisation ont
été limitées aux personnes directement
impliquées dans le travail selon des
employés et d'autres personnes courant
de ces restrictions les chercheurs de
l'entreprise ont déclaré qu'il leur
avait été demandé de soumettre des
travaux sur des sujets sensibles à
l'examen des avocats de l'entreprise qui
ont parfois demandé des exemples de
problèmes à supprimer des messages
internes
bon je ne cesse de répéter mais aussi
horrible que les choses soient à
Facebook chez Google c'est en fait pire
l’équipe a été démantelé pour être sûr
qu'aucune donnée interne compromettante
ne pourra être liquée et pour s'assurer
que les préoccupations soulevées en
interne sont littéralement maltraités
par les dirigeants de Google bref
clairement Facebook et Google effectue
constamment un énorme biais de sélection
dans les informations qu'il choisisse de
rendre public est-ce pour autant qu'on
ne peut rien et qu'on ne doit rien
inférer de ce qui a été révélé
absolument pas si Facebook disposait de
données solides qui montraient que des
mesures drastiques avaient été mises en
place pour lutter contre la
désinformation et les appels à la haine
et que ces mesures étaient très
efficaces alors Facebook les aurait
clairement montré avec beaucoup de
fierté en fait on a là un cas où en un
sens l'absence de preuve de sécurité est
une preuve de l'absence de sécurité
après tout Facebook a beaucoup cherché
des preuves de sécurité et s'il en avait
trouvé il les aurait clairement partagé
et donc oui dans certains contextes
l'absence de preuve peut être tout à
fait une preuve de l'absence notamment
quand ce qui a eu énormément de
recharges qui auraient probablement
déterré des preuves si ses preuves
existaient bon je le masque un petit peu
en disant cela car elles sont de preuves
c'est une notion très mathématique qui
devrait être restreinte aux
mathématiques ici il s'agit davantage de
donner très convaincante en faveur de la
sécurité or les données sont toujours
sujettes à du bruit et des biais et donc
ne peuvent pas être aussi concluantes
que des preuves mathématiques mais bon
on peut oublier ça aujourd'hui et le
problème du biais de sélection dont j'ai
parlé ici mais bien sûr pas spécifique à
Facebook en fait tout groupe militant va
inéluctablement cadrer la discussion
autour d'un sujet de sorte à mettre
toute la lumière sur quelques données de
leur choix et à ignorer l'ensemble de
toutes les données ou l'ensemble de
toutes les problématiques mais ça ne
veut pas dire que le choix de quelle
donnée révélé est la nature de ces
données doivent être ignorées ces
données restent informatives pourvu que
l'on tienne suffisamment compte du biais
de sélection et quand même en prenant en
compte le biais de sélection les données
sont particulièrement compromettantes
comme par exemple au hasard dans le cas
des révélations de Frances hawgen contre
Facebook il y a de quoi déplacer
radicalement notre curseur de crédence
mais bien sûr pour en arriver à de
telles conclusions il est critique de
bien analyser les données en question
ainsi que le biais de sélection qu'elles
ont subi bref bien analyser des données
sujettes à des biais de sélection c'est
compliqué
je vais finir avec les quelques
remarques sur la manière d'aéienne
d'analyser des données sujettes à
d'énormes biais de sélection et le point
clé le point crucial le point qu'il faut
absolument avoir en tête c'est que pour
analyser de telles données il faut
modéliser le biais de sélection
malheureusement nous avons tendance à
sauter cette étape si cruciale et c'est
pour cela que le paradoxe des deux
enfants en particulier nous rend fou
j'en profite pour vous encourager à voir
ou à revoir cette vidéo ce paradoxe des
deux enfants c'est vraiment mon paradoxe
préféré d'une part parce que je l'aurais
mâché sans relâche pendant plus de 5 ans
mais d'autre part et surtout parce qu'il
contient en lui une énorme partie des
difficultés d'adopter un raisonnement
vraiment bayésien en particulier pour
être un bon bayésien il faut modéliser
le biais de sélection et ça ça demande
d'avoir un a priori avant d'analyser les
données sur la manière dont ces données
ont été générés et en particulier sur la
manière dont elles ont été biaisées par
un biais de sélection potentielle comme
le dit le proverbe payésien sans
préjugés aucune conclusion ne peut être
tirée et ça c'est d'autant plus le cas
des qui sont constamment sujettes à
toutes sortes de biais observationnels
mais du coup nécessairement les
conclusions qu'on tirera dépendront
inéluctablement de notre préjugé sur le
biais de sélection qu'on subit les
données c'est pour cela que le bazanisme
est une éclablement subjective il est
sujet à nos données et en particulier il
dépend de ce qu'on croit du biais de
sélection consubique les données alors
bien sûr un bon bayésien il faut
envisager plusieurs biais de sélection
crédible qu'on puisse subir les données
tirer des conclusions pour chacun des
scénarios envisagés et envisager tout le
multivers bayésien des mondes probables
sachant les données que l'on a qui ont
résulte et bon faire tout ça en pratique
ça devient vite très compliqué mais
histoire d'être un peu plus formel on
peut typiquement imaginer qu'il existe
des données brutes des qui ont été
collectées mais qu'il y a eu un
traitement de ces données de sorte que
les données observées sont ensuite des
données hauts qui sont une fonction F2D
des données brutes et là de façon
critique pour appliquer la formule de
base il faut absolument tenir en compte
de la fonction de sélection F qui a
modifié les données brutes en données
observées oh et en fait si vous écrivez
soigneusement les équations des
probabilités vous verrez que les lois
des probabilités vous imposent de le
faire correctement en pratique bien sûr
effectuez tous ces calculs et très
compliqué mais on peut les approximer en
faisant tout simplement l'effort
intellectuel de penser tout le flux des
données qui ont conduit à l'observation
de la donnée observée au camp Facebook
annonce meta quelles sont toutes les
histoires qui ont pu conduire Facebook à
annoncer meta et surtout lesquels sont
le plus crédible quand les
manifestations antibactinales mettent en
avant le chiffre de 25000 vaccinés morts
quelle est l'histoire derrière ce
chiffre comment ce chiffre a été
sélectionné parmi l'ensemble de toutes
les statistiques au sujet des vaccins
mieux encore oublier un instant que vous
connaissez ce chiffre et réfléchissez à
toutes les branches du multivers
bayésien et à tous les chiffres que vous
pouvez imaginer avoir découverts dans
les branches parallèles du multivers
maintenant comparez les chiffres
auxquels il était raisonnable de
s'attendre avant de connaître le chiffre
qui est effectivement tombé êtes-vous
alors surpris du qui est tombé si avant
de connaître ce chiffre vous vous
attendiez vous vous attendiez à ce que
ces manifestations annoncent un chiffre
beaucoup plus faible alors d'après la
formule de base en gros vous devriez
augmenter vos crédences en la
dangerosité du vaccin mais si vous aviez
prédit un chiffre de cet ordre de
grandeur voire supérieur un an plus tôt
il y a alors pas de quoi augmenter vos
crédences en la dangerosité du vaccin
telle une manière plus bayezenne de
raisonner avec des données sujettes au
biais de sélection ce qui encore une
fois représente en fait quasiment toutes
les données ok vous avez accès